Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, on a reçu une question du public,
qu'on va aller écouter :
« J'aimerais bien ça aller vous rencontrer
et puis aller dans le Grand Nord,
mais c'est très difficile d'aller dans le Grand Nord.
Moi, je suis une personne
qui voyage quand même beaucoup.
Puis, à chaque fois je regarde les prix
des billets d'avion,
c'est vraiment inaccessible.
Si un jour c'est plus accessible,
j'aimerais bien ça aller vous voir. »
Merci beaucoup pour la question.
C'est un enjeu qui ne concerne pas uniquement
les communautés québécoises, mais aussi
les communautés des Premières Nations.
C'est à dire, une accessibilité
aux régions où on habite.
Il ne faut pas oublier que les Premières Nations,
on est souvent dans des régions assez éloignées,
qui des fois n'ont aucun accès à la route,
ou même des fois par la mer à leur communauté.
Donc c'est souvent l'avion, le train,
et c'est certain que l'éloignement
fait que le transport va être
extrêmement cher, extrêmement coûteux.
On sait que pour aller dans le Grand Nord,
le billet d'avion coûte des fois deux fois plus cher
que pour se rendre
à Paris ou à Londres.
Donc, c'est certain qu'entre Paris et
Londres, et Kuujjuaq, souvent on va avoir
l'attirance pour aller dans les vieux
pays. Mais, un grand obstacle, justement,
à se rendre dans les communautés
et qui faciliterait la multiplication
des transports peut-être en commun,
comme les autobus, des trains beaucoup
plus sécuritaire ou beaucoup plus accessibles,
et des billets d'avion moins cher,
ça serait que les gens du Québec
décident d'aller visiter leurs régions. On a vu
une augmentation justement du tourisme,
comme sur la Côte-Nord, ce qui fait
que l'accessibilité s'agrandit et fait
baisser les coûts. Ensuite, c'est
de rentrer dans les communautés,
mais ça, ça se fait lors de pow-wow.
Il y a des événements publics ouverts à tous
et vous êtes très invités à venir partager
avec nous. Mais, vraiment,
je pense que l'accessibilité première,
c'est vraiment le coût des transports.
Et plus les gens vont s'y intéresser,
plus les routes vont devenir sécuritaire grâce,
justement, à la pression et au support
des communautés non autochtones, plus les
gens vont êtes intéressés à y aller.
C'est certain que de se tourner les yeux
vers l'intérieur de notre territoire
plutôt que vers d'autres pays,
ça peut être la première porte d'entrée
pour aller créer une réconciliation
et justement des communautés beaucoup plus serrées.
Merci pour la question,
j'espère que j'ai pu y répondre
et j'espère que vous allez nous en envoyer
d'autres à Parole autochtone.
Je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine!